you're just dab waiting on the traffic
light just Bop in just bopping some
beats you look to your left
I would look immediately back forward
bam and fam I would recline the chair
I'm gone
[Music]
as you already know go straight into the
episode and we're going to the IG
question the age question is uh what's
an excuse you've used to get out of a
dates and as per usual guys the
responses
juicy all right then let's have a bit of
this then
I'm just you know how it is guys I'm
just gonna reel them off let's roll them
off Jay
and I mean tree to know which one you're
gonna laugh at the most
right
so again what's an excuse you've used to
get out of a date right I once said I
once said my spirit animal doesn't agree
with crossbreeds and as a lion I can't
mix with pigs
who sent that a male or female
in it
obviously a theme I can't mix with pigs
my spirit animals are lining I can't mix
with pigs sorry I just can't be doing up
oinks anymore I can't Wild
he wanted to take me out when I got back
from holiday and I said I may be a bit
tired for a few weeks
and her response be the polite version
of [ __ ] off oh there isn't there isn't
there's literally nothing worse with an
X at the end with a kiss I might be
tired for a few weeks x x
what does that even mean bro it means
never it might be tired there isn't a
reality in this Dimension or the next
where you will be taking me out there
will never be a situation where me and
you will be in the same room together so
I don't really understand why you think
you've got the gore to send me that fam
I'll be um I respond because I'm polite
polite I'm very polite that's the reason
why you're getting this very polite
response but never again yeah leave it
leave it oh that's dread I might be
tired for a few weeks Ah that's true I
couldn't receive that message I promise
I'm not receiving it I promise you're
not receiving it
I couldn't receive that message because
it's so blatantly obvious it's such a
par like I mean what am I supposed to
say I'm a human being too what the [ __ ]
am I supposed to say okay okay oh say no
more shot me shot me on the fourth week
tell me when you feeling better babe let
me know if you need some soup
waste man
blocked
pretended I didn't know who the number
was and replied who is this
who is this
what time should I start getting ready
because um you know the movie starts at
seven I'm gonna pick you up around five
so what should you say get ready for
four
who is this who is this
pardon James I dropped my phone
I would drop my phone I'm waiting for
the laughs lulls who is this not even a
no no who is this who is this question
mark question mark question about
exclamation yeah
who is this
do we not have chat history bro do we
not have to spoke to you five minutes
ago what do you mean who is this
nah bro that's [ __ ] audacity and then
you try and reply with Vigor one tick
one tick one tick and the picture's
distance the picture's gone it's just a
great thing now you can't even vent you
literally
oh look at my phone
ah I was scream at the phone
that's the only thing I can do I'm
looking hold it with two hands and
scream
[ __ ] scream
I'm so sorry for the audio listeners
that got an ear full of me screaming
just now I apologize I was too much in
character God that's funny that was too
much a character and I apologize
because some of you are deaf right now
and I'm so so sorry [ __ ] that's funny
I'm so sorry that's funny all right back
to it what's an excuse you've used to
get out of a date
hid under the table head under the table
from a few cops walking by and told him
I had a warrant out for my arrest
I would have so many questions
so many questions [ __ ] sake
that I was in a car crash 20 minutes
later he was in a lane next to me no can
you imagine
can you imagine you're just dab waiting
at a traffic light just bopping just
bopping some beats you look to your left
I will look immediately back forward bam
and fam I would recline the chair
I'm gone bro I'm gone I'll bet it
because I have no call in this situation
I couldn't even like give her the look
and then like look back it would be like
look you'll see You'd physically see my
pupils dilate off
number
and my phone's off while I'm sitting
here you'll see me turn my phone off you
see you just swiping closed
[Laughter]
and she's screaming out the window James
she's one she's one down a window but
you're with yours up and your music's
blasting so you can't even hear James
are you just facing bro
you're all she'll hear in the distances
I lied all right I lied all right
I'm [ __ ] sorry oh that's jokes oh
Jesus
told him I needed to go home and take my
medication if I don't I'll start
twitching
yeah oh yeah they're on the actual date
I need to get home and take my
medication what's the bounce
I'll start I'll wait I can hate that
I'll say twitch
they're nuts
how about that how about that [ __ ] on
these nuts hey come on
take me home I need to go yeah I don't
have medication get me home because this
has just gone from bad to worse this has
gone from bad to worse I was on the
fence I was trying to be polite so
literally you [ __ ] it get it home
twitch on these nuts
you just beside
oh is that I swear sorry so you actually
just made up I was joking okay you know
come on man I have to on the drive I
have to say so what did I do before the
whole picture of my nuts little thing
what was it that made you decide I need
to fake a syndrome to get me out of here
to take me home what what did I do wrong
so much what did I do and I have and I
would have to ask her probably like five
minutes into the journey so she she's
got no excuse about to answer oh it
can't be five minutes before she gets
yeah you're answering as soon as we get
out of the car park yeah onto the main
road so what did I do wrong what when
you made up the thing like oh I'm Ill
yeah what what did I say what did I do
that made you like is it me is it just
me is it just me in general as a human
it's my height isn't it
she'd be like yeah you said you were six
foot but you're five seven on what
planet imagine imagine if you just
thought it was a convoating yeah a convo
team yeah and you're like so what did I
actually do yeah like I don't know I
thought we were having a laughter yeah
and you're like and I like the food was
good the music was good I thought we
were vibing like what is it that I
actually did and her reply is on what
planet are you six one
it won't be the same thing again
it would be the same to I'll grab this
pillow face my front and keep driving
because she's right my chest would
collapsed she's right on what planet do
you think you're six foot one
drive shut the [ __ ] the [ __ ] up and
drive no reality can you reach the
pedals Drive
[ __ ] on what planet
jokes oh Jesus Christ
didn't get out of the date but he tried
to kiss me and I screamed for help
nah bro it reminds me did you see that
thing the other day the boxing thing
boxing thing oh
another one of these [ __ ]
like YouTube boxes oh thank God I didn't
see it ksi's promotion was doing
something oh the kiss thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah I saw that oh bro she got but
he laughed in her face
he laughed in her face well played KSI
he laughed in her face it's dread
because what I can't remember her name I
don't know I don't know this yacht's
name someone will know any of their
names bro try to lift KSI at the press
conference and my man
she was like what the one girl said to
her you've got a man he's in a crowd
yeah if I've got a man would I do this
try to lips kiss like Kiss like peel
back main pill back and then he laughed
he gave her a nervous laugh and then you
heard the last reverberating the thing
and then he pissed himself he pissed
himself
she didn't make eye contact with him
again she couldn't she stayed focused
here and just held the most brutal
awkward smile I've ever seen she was
just like
she hadn't Oh ponytail was just bubbling
and she was like get me off this [ __ ]
Steve I'm gonna die get me off the stage
I'm going to [ __ ] die someone put a
Billet in my head now now bro cause it's
embarrassing I found I'd have to grab a
mic and be like someone end it someone
in my life now and that's when the chick
on the other imagine imagine she was
like you push your bang fight done fight
done
I told you you like how did the weigh-in
go
yeah well
thing is we were eye to eye and homeboy
was like oh I know your girl I know your
girl and I'm like I don't have a girl
and he's like yes you do she's in the
crowd yeah I beat it it's all this and
I'm like shut up bro if I had a girl
would I do this and I went to grab the
the promoter girl and lips her and she
died back got it back I already know
your jaw will hit the floor at this
point she darted back and I was
humiliated by tried to stay poised and
focused okay I got Goosebumps all over
my body yeah if I try to say poison I
face my man I tried to give him the evil
eyes alive off but the yacht was pissing
myself
she was howling to the point where she
couldn't breathe so the guy with the mic
was saying something I grabbed it from
him to just announce to the crowd like
haha I'm embarrassed I've made a fool of
myself and someone ended homeboy took
that opportunity to lay the dirtiest
bang in my temple and just knocked me
for six
he knocked me on my ass and I was
unconscious for a few minutes
the gravity well the friction from me
hitting the floor yanked my trunks down
and my soft tool was just flat on the
stage while I was unconscious
so the Medics had to pull me pull my
[ __ ] up and drag me off the stage I was
too heavy and they dragged me off the
stage and here I am talking to you so
after all that you didn't get weighed
they didn't even weigh me in
James I don't think you understand that
kind of sequence of events would make my
day I'd be so angry at the same time I
don't even know why I'd be angry firm I
know you don't know you know who to be
angry at bro that's the thing I mean you
literally did this to yourself facts
I'll be so angry but I'll be in bits
right I know you'll be laughing and
you're like I can't wait to talk to you
about this on the pot of black the thing
is I don't think I can go back
was out
you won't see me again bro this is our
last hurray you ain't seeing me again
I've asked a promotion for my 50 bucks
and I'm moving to Alaska oh bro that's
too funny that's too funny I said his
soft tour just out it's embarrassing
right again what's an excuse you used to
get out of a date I told I told him my
parents arranged my marriage with a
second cousin wow what the [ __ ] bro bro
just to get out of a date what the [ __ ]
and the thing is as well what annoys me
about these ones is how dare you have
the goal to come up with such an
explicit lie yeah intricate explicit Let
Me Down Easy
fam it's that simple you're playing
games with your lies yeah yeah yeah
because you have to keep up with it yeah
you're making up experiments to say will
he believe this a gullible prick
believe this I'm gonna marry my second
cousin so I can't go on a date with you
oh Madness but just with your girls
giggling not an excuse but he pulled up
outside mine so I turned off all the
lights and dropped to the floor
jokes
women don't fear consequences
[ __ ] they don't give a flying [ __ ] James
another example
not a date but but to stop him from
kissing me I ate a peanut M M's because
he's allergic no you didn't
it's another they don't give a [ __ ]
about consequences
he could have died
didn't use an excuse I just said I was
going for a smoke and ran out the back
oh God bro how bad are these dates bro
wow how bad are these dates I don't know
who they're meeting and where they're
meeting these people but hey it's
entertainment at the end of the day I
saved my boy's number as my world with
an engagement ring next to it and told
him to call me she saw it stood up and
left
well played sir that's gang well played
that's gang sorry stood up and left oh
wow well Blazer wow that's complex yeah
because layers wow well done facts bro
found out he's a Serial cheat I asked
him when his birthday was and said
let me start again sorry found out he's
a Serial Chief I asked him when his
birthday was and said I'm sorry our
horoscopes don't match
piss off
I went on a date he told me he was 5 11.
when I got there he was five seven I
walked out
simple very tall I said I wasn't feeling
well then proceeded to go on another
date with a better option oh that
happens all the time I bet it does of
course it happens of course all the time
bro
of course it does I could never catch
her out
and acknowledge that that was a better
option imagine you just see James 2.0
taller wama more light-skinned more
lights The Bluest of eyes
yeah as long it's are you Mauritius it's
one of them ones where let's say you
were meant to go Cinema or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you're like [ __ ]
I don't really want to watch this movie
bro I wanna watch this movie man [ __ ] it
I have a group of myself I'm gonna go my
brother let's say you end up going by
yourself for example you go through you
know it's one of the ones where you
cross paths so you're here you're
walking on your jimmies God you're
walking on your TV let's say you're
walking from the um where you buy a
popcorn probably like to the toilet yeah
yeah and they're walking from the toilet
to the [ __ ] screen you're holding
puckers you're holding popcorn on a
drink you've got no one to party
oh you waste man and they're hand in
hand they've got like elbow and elbow
locked she sees you you see her you know
you've got you can't say a thing you see
you see him yeah I see you I look up and
the fact that I have to raise my chest
yeah coach just pause onto my t-shirt
you're like oh makes sense makes sense
you can't say a thing say less say less
say less you are better than me and she
said you
she said you and now I'm here reminding
her why she's with you and not with me
basically where's your dick appointment
tonight
right there right there right there
there's my dick appointment
go and watch the movie by yourself and
enjoy yourself because we are not even
going to hang around for the movie we're
gonna go and smash so enjoy your jumbo
Coke so go and play and your sweet and
Salted Popcorn because you're a loser
and you're by yourself bro go home and
have a wank after and just block my
number Midway because I'm never
answering again because I can't be
bothered to block you yep block my
number because I can't be tired find
your name in the legs of [ __ ] losers
in my WhatsApp I can't block yourself
wow
wow I'm gonna get my back blown out
block yourself
oh I promise you I'll leap down those
lips there guys
I can never leave headphones
sparkly staircase I can't be mid movie
Just matching popcorn engulfed and just
hear screams and just see your head
popcorn a Coke flying downstairs
I was set up James I'm set up like
America what's going on I said like a
[ __ ] meerkat bro what happened what's
happened you go to see me and then he
was there bleeding out and here you see
a WhatsApp conversation where all caps
block yourself
block yourself and a video of her cheeks
just get clapped no no
the biggest cheeks you've ever seen oh
just scared
on the thickest tour you've ever
witnessed
and you're just dead
yeah why that makes it it makes sense
all the sense and I just feel like say
less so you just carry on watching the
movie
that's hilarious wow
oh Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ
funny enough we went to the cinema
together but he brought his sister I
went to the toilet during the movie and
dipped of course that's weird it sounds
like he was trying to done off the date
before she could oh Rags rags
told her told her I forgot something in
the oven at 40 not 45 I can't get the
words out today told her I forgot
something in the oven at 450 degrees
Fahrenheit so specific
Oh my days that's true I work seven days
a week I still live with my husband oh
raw I left
sweet at me
I left our table to use the toilet went
home and texted him I couldn't find you
so I left
I knew
fake to fit at the restaurant table I
wasn't gonna ditch her at the door I had
to pray the menu first
imagine
you walk in you see the thing you're
like it's like do you remember the
episode of The Office where I think I
have a Pam or uh Phyllis hooks him up
with one of his one of their girls he
meets her at a bar yeah and she comes in
and she's like are you Michael he says
nah he looks like he says Nah and then
the my man the Barista hands him a
coffee says Michael oh Michael oh bro
he's just vets
Rags bro bro imagine I need you to see
the menu first she's a slug but they may
have tiramisu fam they may have Tiramisu
and they may have good oxtails yeah yeah
so let me breathe let me print the menu
man sit down why is the thing and just
quickly
yeah
so what would you be having today um
what's your oxtail saying unfortunately
we've actually run out of the chefs just
said we've just run
ambulance
fam no way up sat across her see that
happen imagine watching her do that and
then while she's doing it you see her
like pee
I
[ __ ]
I'm leaving I'm leaving I will kiss my
teeth and leave bro I would kiss my
teeth and leave that's [ __ ] that's
all [ __ ] you didn't tell me you're
epileptic before yeah bro you didn't
mention none of these syndrome
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] shaking I'll Stand
I'll stand up I'd go to a side of the
table
stop [ __ ] shaking right now right
[ __ ] now you're embarrassing yourself
so [ __ ] shake it now she has to
double down five she's going for it now
she's going for it foam the works yeah
yeah oh my days I'm sweating
so [ __ ] shaking
Oh my days oh
oh God fam she just said hell no and
disappeared into the crowd
fam imagine being at like Park life or
something you see it okay you just see a
thing you're like oh okay babes come
here she's like yo hell no she
disappears like Homer in the bush just
walks back I'm not on it no no no no no
my autistic cousin swallowed my fish she
blocked me after that
but yeah that was the last one wow wow
that was jokes that was very funny
welcome to the show guys yeah welcome
guys as always guys if you're new here
please what you need to do right now is
pause the episode and head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
it's gonna cost you three pound a month
10p a day you need to run the pizza sng
why because over there you have cult
baby status okay if you want to be part
of the cult we're going to get the Log
Cabin we're gonna get the white robes
obviously Yeezys are um they're
tentative because of what he's doing on
a mat yeah he's on a Madness so the
Footwear is optional
um so white robes optional Footwear and
we're just going to be over there
laughing and clapping cheeks that's what
Colts do baby and that's what we do so
head on over to patreon become one of
the cult babies and on top of that while
you're waiting binge all the episodes
we've done over the last three years
every Thursday we have a new episode for
you as well guys enjoy indoctrinating
yourself into the culture head on over
to our Discord get involved with
everyone over there get the chirps in
get the Selfies up there sell yourself
okay sell yourself give and you will
receive thanks all right guys that's
patreon.com sheets and gigs as always
guys if you are watching on YouTube
please subscribe to the channel we
really appreciate it chop sitting in the
comments I like the video if you liked
the video and lastly for our audio
listeners our podcast app listeners the
ones that like to listen to the smooth
mellow sounds of your boys over here at
shifts and gigs please leave us a nice
review it means the world to us so every
week and we mean it every week facts
five stars is preferable but just tell
us how you feel okay five stars is
preferable but just tell us how you feel
guys all right and without any further
Ado my comrade over here firelord ways
is going to hit us with a cheeky fun
fact to set us off in a good mood let's
go let's go MythBusters episode Help
free innocent man after 35 years in
prison yeah John Galvin proved his
innocence using evidence from a
mythbuster episode after spending 35
years in prison John Garvin had been in
jail for 21 years when he caught a rerun
of Mythbusters in 2007.
tear shock and Delight the episode
definitely so sorry to his shock and his
Delight the episode definitely proved
that you couldn't ignite a pool of
gasoline with a lit cigarette something
that government was accused of doing in
the late 1980s
resulting in the deaths of two men in
Chicago 15 years after the episode Gavin
and his attorneys from an innocent from
an Innocence Project convinced the judge
to vacate his conviction and the
convictions of the two other men who had
also been found guilty
wow that's insane bro
insane so he got him put in prison I'm
assuming for murder for throwing a lit
cigarette and gasoline yeah and it
exploded exploded in the pool
yeah yeah
that's impossible wow interesting
impossible interesting could it ignite a
pool of gasoline with a lit cigarette
wow that's mad bro that is mad and the
judge the fact that they couldn't even
prove it and just said they put two into
the game and said he must have done it
it must have been the lit cigarette and
then myth bosses just be like yeah bro
I've tested it it doesn't work yeah
that's that's not a thing right bro it
just doesn't work it's impossible and
they're like raw 35 I'm not even 35 yet
bro yeah wow good shout we're not 35 yet
James we've lived we've lived James
Jesus Christ
that's insane that's insane insane bro
and what are the odds they just happen
to be watching that that specific
episode and seen that and to get he must
have gotten some reparations
you have to sue
oh true you have to have money too soon
true and for two it's one of the things
is that like
no one knew
everyone thought you everyone yeah even
he did to be fair to be fair he didn't
need to be fair yeah yeah it's not like
he was he was yeah
it's impossible yeah okay I'll shut up
it works shut up shut up shut up have
you not seen Die Hard it [ __ ] works
okay it obviously works
so yeah bro that's mad yeah bro bro I
saw that I was like Wow intriguing very
intriguing right I've got a little bit
of a fun fact oh yeah I thought you said
that okay so I was on Tick Tock this
morning and I saw this and it actually
blew my mind so
um what it was a tick tock about Michael
Jackson okay and it was basically
showing
um
the first time
he ever performed Billie Jean
and it was uh it was either the 20th or
the 25th
um Motown anniversary Awards or whatever
okay basically it come out and
um this is the first time and I'm gonna
try and do it as much just as I can okay
because to really understand how amazing
I found it okay so imagine this this is
in my opinion this one performance would
have redefined
Michael Jackson and pop music forever
okay this one performance okay so right
imagine this we're at the awards yeah
we're all in the crowd yeah Michael
Jackson comes out yep to perform in a
new song that no one's ever heard oh it
was the first time you said this is the
first the song's not released okay it's
the first time anyone's ever heard
Billie Jean yeah far yeah first time
anyone's ever heard Billie Jean and
apparently what they're saying was this
is the first time he'd ever done a
choreographed dance routine since he was
in the Jackson 5. okay so I didn't
realize this but Billie Jean was the
first song where he started doing
Michael stuff before that he was all
doing like disco yeah yeah
this is the first time in this I don't
remember the video
um or Billie Jean is the word he's
walking on the lights
so on this performance he's on stage bro
this is the first time he wears the
glove it's the first time he wears the
Hat this is the first time he's got the
white socks no this is the first time he
does the moon war no first time he does
this no first time he does this no I'm
guessing no one's ever seen anything
like it the crowd must have gone wild
family comes into performance does the
the Hat throw does the whole thing no
one's ever seen it wow and that is what
Michael Jackson's known for Wow imagine
being a grown man and seeing that for
the first time fascinating and be like
what is this song yeah what is he doing
why is he actually do I've never seen a
man move like that and he's just doing
up dance moves and then out of nowhere
he starts doing the moon walk and
everyone's like oh oh my God
it's the devil
it's the devil
Mike's possessed he's possessed
nah oh I would have loved him that one
performer said the place for the rest of
his career that's incredible that set
the pace for the rest of his entire
array I wonder how much train not say
trading like practice he did before that
performance like we must have done a lot
the doc who thought of the movie I don't
know who choreographed that thing he
must have played a big role in it I
don't know who choreographed it oh I'm
very intrigued to see it I really want
to see that now yeah I'll try and find
it yeah um I want to see the actual
performance yeah yeah I found the
performance was sick and the performance
was sick and you could just see everyone
gassed in the crowd
oh
yeah no one's ever seen it [ __ ] that's
the first ever time Billie Jean okay
Michael
I'm pissing I'm pissed because
I was never old enough to see him live
and obviously I'm never going to be able
to see him again and he's one person I
feel like
if we could do like a greatest hits
album or Greatest Hits performance he's
one person I'd love to see
it would have been out of this world it
was in his prime as well one person not
old white knight yeah yeah he's Prime oh
God but like in us in a in a vicinity
where I'm not getting crushed oh yeah
because I don't think you're gonna find
that yeah these men they were going
crazy my man stood up he stood in the he
did the Super Bowl halftime now and he
stood there for like five minutes and
they were screaming they were just
screaming well he did it in silent he
did the silence no he just stood there
and it was screaming he just stood there
before he before he even started the
song he was screaming for five minutes
ten minutes
[ __ ] famous yeah unbearably famous
yeah he was a different level of famous
you couldn't walk anywhere yeah he's
like he was I literally think I'm pretty
sure he literally is like a case of
Elvis The Beatles Michael Jackson
um
lucky there was no social media back
then their lives would have been ruined
it was impossible they were
so [ __ ] famous unbearably famous have
you seen the Elvis movie no you remember
you're talking about it he did a um
Elvis did the first ever like live
stream thing a billion people watched it
a billion people watched it wow a
billion wow
that's interesting Elvis was [ __ ]
famous yeah and he never did an
international tour you only ever
performed in America and he was
literally the most famous person in the
world wow bro
wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] famous man
crazy famous
unbearably famous where he he couldn't
you can't leave your yard because you
will get rugby tackled by a Super Fan
yeah yeah there's level there's
literally levels to this game there's
levels um so this leads me on to my next
thing recommendation the redeem team
I've seen it you've seen it yeah I saw
it um last week yeah I watched it last
week good yeah way better than I thought
it was gonna be in my opinion okay I'll
let you say your piece and I'll say my
peace actually no it's it's my piece
only yeah there's no negativity out and
then I'll say what I want to say okay
it's not it's I want to say it's
negativity I just feel like
I think it could have been better if
they did it as like a two or three part
series as opposed to a one-long movie
okay because it was like an hour and a
half or so yeah I felt like there were
some things that they rushed that it
could have expanded on so just to give
it a bit more you know new ones or
whatever so if it was like a a two-part
episode or maybe a three-part episode I
would have been happy in Kentucky Fair
Play yeah apart from that I enjoyed it I
enjoyed the documentary yeah it was good
I enjoyed it man and I loved how like um
when I was watching it it was like a
nice
I liked how Kobe didn't come until
Midway because once he did it was it was
real you realize that oh this is a Kobe
document yeah yeah it's centered around
here yeah yeah pretty much they gave
everyone else their time before yeah
yeah before he came into it yeah but
what I loved it was just like the scene
that changed it for me was just him
when demo went out to shubs it was at
the gym at four five yeah and then they
got back at 4 30 and he was on his way
to the gym and all of them were like
what was that where are you going I'm
going to the gym I'm going to the gym
bro where the [ __ ] are you man going you
men are going to bed I'm going to I'm
going to the gym the man said the next
day after that couple other men were in
there the next after that couple
whatever man we're in the end of the
week by the end of the week after Squad
the whole Squad was in that half four
and then yeah I think he was like I'm
not gonna lie I'm not going there at
half four I'm not good he's a real [ __ ]
I was like that's food yeah I'm not
gonna lie I was motivated
six that man said I had I have to I need
I'll go after breakfast yeah I'm not
going there was ridiculous ridiculous
I'll see you man when I see you yeah but
I love the energy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah after breakfast
because that's foolishness
that was like wrong and it just made me
remember how good a [ __ ] player Kobe
Bryant was I was obsessed with Kobe
Bryson
I was [ __ ] obsessed with him good
shot and it was like it was it was good
because I never got to see I always saw
the Rivalry between him and LeBron I
never saw the line never saw the love
yep yeah yeah and it was so good it was
heartwarming to see man bro and I didn't
so it's like I didn't know he was that
like anti like anti-social
I never knew he was like a Jordan thing
and he was at that time his life was
going through hell boy he was going
through it and I forgot that because
that was before like my time really
um obviously I was alive but I was a kid
yeah so it was yeah I know you mean yeah
but when I was actually like balls deep
with Kobe and she's like following his
career stuff sorry
um no I'm not sorry
no I'm not sorry
I said what I said
um resume
so when I was like [ __ ] the shower I
was um yeah like all that stuff was
passed yeah yeah and then like you just
saw him to be the absolute baller that
he was until he retired
um
but yeah it was sick second
recommendation I've got is
it's tough for it to be a recommendation
because it actually wasn't as good as I
thought it was going to be okay but it
was a good movie it's a movie on Amazon
Prime called Brothers
okay
is Jake gyland home okay Toby McGuire
and Natalie Portman okay that's a good
car that's a big boy what year did that
come out I can't remember I don't think
90 appointment in who Toby Maguire
it's a good movie brother say let's talk
to me so basically it's all about uh it
follows
um oh my God it follows me I don't know
why sometimes the way you speak it just
sweets man
um so it follows Tim McGuire he's a
Marine right yeah he's a Marine and he
gets um he's a Marine and he's getting
deployed to Afghanistan
his brother Jay General has just come
out of pen okay for robbing a bank okay
he's just about a pen and he's him and
talking about are close [ __ ] close
Natalie Portman is Toby Maguire's wife
so Tom McGuire goes off to uh
Afghanistan he gets captured and he's a
prisoner of war oh sure they think he's
dead oh [ __ ] so the time that he's away
oh no
they didn't want that an apartment get
pretty close oh God they get very close
I'm not going to lie to you the sexual
tension in this [ __ ] oh God is mixed
with guilt so the sex and the guilt and
the last and the the grief oh it's too
much
I need to release it somehow they're
crying and they're angry and they're
happy and they're just ah it's the whole
thing's just long and he's got typical
guys I've got two daughters so Jake Dino
kind of kind of steps in as like a
father role as well he loves these
[ __ ] kids he loves these [ __ ] kids
it's heartwarming and they [ __ ] love
him as well
um but anyway he's a prisoner of war
yeah it all goes off yeah he comes back
and he is tapped oh I'm not surprised
when he gets back I'm not he's [ __ ]
tapped bro and he's I'm do I'm
disappointed but not really
um because I saw this spoiler on Tick
Tock before I even watched the movie and
I was like oh my God I need to see this
okay um
first of all one thing it examines is
that females are innately born with
spite in their veins
[Laughter]
those will make up lies to hurt you yeah
and they're born with it yeah
and because there's a Tom McGuire is so
paranoid that Jake's been banging his
misses okay
so spoiler alert they didn't bang okay
but the whole yeah they may as well yeah
yeah so he's he comes back paranoid says
his brother were you banging it were you
banging her Jake's like chill the [ __ ]
out yeah you've been through a lot how
long was he like months okay months
months I don't think he was gone a year
but he's gone for months [ __ ] yeah bro
[ __ ] they were torturing that there [ __ ]
they were torturing him out there so he
went through it [ __ ] yeah comes back
says to her what are you banging her man
says chill out I don't want to hear this
nonsense I'm just happy to have you
heard this isn't YouTube yeah yeah yeah
says to his missus well you banging him
she says chill out just stop yeah
literally [ __ ] stop at separate
conversations separate conversations
he's like say this
because he's so tapped yeah his eldest
daughter is struggling he's been gone
she's connected with Jake Gyllenhaal who
now has no reason to be around the house
every day and she the guy she gets back
is is a shadow of what left she used to
love her dad he came back [ __ ]
cracked and she's like who is this
brother yeah so one day she gets vex
she says you're just pissed off because
my mom would rather sleep with Uncle
Tommy than you she's a little girl she
says they have sex all the time
fam at the dinner table
Matt says what fam fam the China he says
what
she's like yeah
the mom says why did you say that no one
guess what the [ __ ] did you say that you
know it's not true yeah he's a little
girl she has no contact for why she's
even saying this but she has spite in
her veins and she knew what would get
she somehow knew what it would do what
he would do to his words yeah she said
they have sex all the time
mine said swear down from long story
short spoiler it gets a gun and he's
waving it
turbo guy gets a gun and starts waving
it in the kitchen everywhere in the
kitchen and I did a table in the street
the police come he's waving it if I'm
he's waving it and then he brings it
boiler alert
he brings it here and says I'm I'm
locking this whole dance
someone shoot me I'm shooting myself oh
my I'm knocking this off I can't live
like this oh my uh I can't live like
this
he's a it's a roller coaster who had
ah I said a lot but it's worth a watch
it's a roller coaster giving me cherry
Vibes without the brother
Cherry Tom Holland wow what the one I
watched on the track oh I haven't yeah
he goes through I need to watch that
that every time I S I looked at your
screen something else was happening he
went through it
that looked depressing bro yeah but damn
okay cool Brothers yeah on Amazon
Brothers magic say less it was say less
it was a disaster that whole thing was a
disaster say less okay I'm gonna watch
it Jake you're on WhatsApp
I can imagine he wants a
but then I just think like this is my
brother's wife the kids are my nieces
like I can't this is this is conflict
bro Too Close yeah too close do you know
what I mean
it's too close yeah every angle yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] for everything our
whole thing is long I would be noshing
off oh of course the clarity yeah just
for clarity alone fam he was wanking and
crying in that movie every time he felt
it well enough you were burst into tears
because he's like this is my brother's
wife
but I'm trying to smash I need some
I'm here every day
run me certain did I do like a did I get
touchy feely you can see
you can see
yeah yeah I'm just gonna say it's not
just Jake that wants it I was saying
let's not just Jacob Natalie's a little
Black Swan yes thick in that room oh I
can imagine no they're swallowing spit
in there
it's my favorite thing on this planet
James
it does something to me
bro
cut the attention with a knife say less
[ __ ] machete it's so thick
that's what she said were you hey yeah
ah oof
half legs just walk on don't come in
foreign
there must be a better way to get my
dagger clean and shiny I've heard there
is bro there is I've heard there is
do tell
what is the name I've heard there's a
young manscape 4.0
4.0 is doing bits bro oh the 4.0 it is a
life savior it is a savior of my life oh
facts bro
[ __ ]
thank you 4.0 manscape perfect package
rags
along with myself
young Fu had and six million other men
worldwide that's 12 million balls 12
million a bollock have joined the
movement
by going to manscape.com [ __ ] and when
they got there they decided they wanted
20 off and free shipping so guess what
they did so what they did is they
grabbed the code from your boys over
here you know the cult babies gave you
the code and it's sng Sierra November
Golf and that's going to give you 20 off
plus free shipping manscape.com is the
site you want to use guys get that
perfect package facts okay lawnmower 4.0
no more Cuts bruises Nooks crannies keep
the dagger slick and ready for wherever
the night may take you guys we're ready
for walk let's go ready for work we're
ready for war we're ready for more yeah
come on man come on all right guys let's
get back to the episode okay cool right
we've got a trash news okay so it's not
even a trash news it's more of an
unfortunate piece of news I'm sure
you've heard everyone's seen it as well
Cartoon Network's shut down officially
it's been absorbed by like Warner
Brothers or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so and obviously that got me
thinking about like Nostalgia growing up
and blah blah blah so that leads on to
my question to you what would you say is
your top five Cartoon Network cartoons
of all time
take your time I'll tell you what I'm
going to Google them so I actually have
reference because I don't want to start
mixing yeah yeah because I've got my
five I wrote my five down and you guys
as well at home please write in the
comments what your top five or top three
whichever one you want to do
um Cartoon Network cartoons of all time
let us know guys let me see if see you
guys match up with us okay right so
before I go into the Nostalgia ones yeah
I'm gonna give a few that are current
yeah absolute Banger just um what are
they called um honorary mentions
The Amazing World of Gumballs
unbelievably good job Adventure Time are
you gonna say though [ __ ] show bro
Regular Show yeah Geez Louise
um we bare Bears is there another one I
knew you were gonna say that as well
yeah we bare Bears banging okay cool
jokes right so
my favorites oh wow bro that's some
unbelievable ones on here let me have a
look see Pokemon was on there till 2017.
jeez right so it's in terms of nostalgia
I'm gonna go with
this is what I used to bang through so
I'm gonna go with starting from the top
Regular Show is going to stay into my
top okay Powerpuff Girls okay
another honorary mentioned but I can't
put it in my top because it was just
scary Courage the Cowardly Dog Okay
[ __ ] hell what terrifying show that
was okay okay they put me through it
every time I watch that show
um Ed Edd and Eddie 100 Dexter's Lab
110 percent
cow chicken was a banger Cow and Chicken
was a banger
what mama had a chicken mama had a cow
that's jokes
um oh that's jokes right so I'm torn
between Samurai Jack wow throwback Cow
and Chicken and maybe Johnny Bravo
I'm gonna go Cow and Chicken say like
that Cow and Chicken was a show that was
jokes bro that
um oh bro that devil Brett
fam he was a pee though yeah facts he
was a pedo right my honorary mentions
carbon chicken
um
Ren Stimpy Ren and Stimpy
um Auggie and the Cockroaches wow
um Wacky Races
bro was that on car Network yeah Wacky
Races yeah bro
um
what other ones are there Tom and Jerry
on here as well Tom and Jerry's Model
Five is it yeah Rags I watched Tom and
Jerry every single day brother so my top
five Tom and Jerry Dragon Ball Z
Pokemon yeah yeah Ed Edd and Eddie yeah
yeah Looney Tunes
fair play those are my top five fair
play I am I've got oh bro there's so
many more on here oh I know there's so
many more wait what show was what
channel was jaolin Showdown on Xiao
Lin's Showdown was a shower I think it
was only for like a couple years bro
that was a show that if if that was on
Cartoon Network that's me Showdown was a
show that was only like two seasons
I forgot about that wow Adventures of
Jackie Chan should be up there as a
honorary mentioned events of Jackie Chan
Adventures of Jackie Chan Showdown
um [ __ ] I can't remember what was
Justice League on
I also started watching Dragon Ball Z
originally on Cartoon Network when I was
a kid or Toonami whatever it was I was
only watching on car Network for years
yeah Pokemon
um did you ever use the word late night
Cartoon Network and they had um like
Space Ghost or whatever it was the worst
show I think so some weird animated talk
show
um actually maybe not then maybe not and
they had um Animaniacs I loved anime
Animaniacs yeah man that was that's an
honorary mention as well because I
remember look I was going through like
their shows and I saw what I was
thinking what a show an amazing show
that's a Warner Brothers show yeah yeah
bro um I think I had another honorary
mention just in my head now
um
Mega's XLR magazine
do you remember that yes yes I do the
chubby white bread
and we had the yeah the Playboy yeah as
a Transformer oh yeah yeah
there were some shows back in the day
brother whoa some shows back in the day
I was I was content with Cartoon Network
for so many years of my life so yeah
because even when I was moving into my
teens bro I had um had everything I'm
pretty sure I started watching Naruto
and Cartoon Network I started watching I
never watched Naruto I was watching
Digimon Accord Network you get on car
Network Pokemon Yu-Gi-Oh
um
oh code Network had yeah they had
everything they had me on ropes yeah yes
bro they had everything even did you
ever watch codename kids Next Door of
course
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God that's the Nostalgia was sick
let us know honorary mentions top three
top five whatever just list them all man
because I'm sure you guys are as like
you felt it as much as I did when I saw
car network has been Network Cartoon
Network has been dissolved already yeah
dissolved by Warner Brothers and
thinking that was literally a lot of our
childhood it was everything it was
everything all of my shows that I used
to watch literally were Cartoon Network
they had it oh man I was in Cartoon
Network my sister was watching trouble
yeah oh she's older yeah
she was allowed to yeah yeah yeah when I
moved over to trouble that's when I have
my adolescence
that's what I was watching real shows
that's when I was watching What My Wife
and Kids one-on-one bro Sister Sister
all of them yeah yeah oh fam wow what a
throwback that's my childhood that is
and it's just gone now it's gone that's
what I'm saying bro that was my
childhood bro this is what I'm saying
bro I used to love everything Mojo Jojo
my guy Mojo Jojo
power of girls were the one because they
actually had they actually had villains
that were ready to round yeah actually
that's actually true Powerpuff Girls was
actually apart from like when you talk
about like Dragon Ball Z and stuff like
that yeah and stuff like that pop-up
goes is a call too family had feelings
bro arms in there Mojo Jojo they used to
Tamp him up so his brain was hanging out
of his shell Gang Green gang gang green
gang that's how we're doing up drugs and
[ __ ] yeah yeah and then he got like the
amoeba boys
Sam when they introduced the Rowdy Rough
Boys
the Rowdy Rough Boys the anti-heroes bro
bro she got real okay was different [ __ ]
got real with the wrong Rough Boy
different yeah yeah yeah and then you
had the devil yeah on the side that used
to just turn around like that yeah yeah
oh he was terrified he was terrified he
was the boss boss yeah he was the final
boss we're never gonna be able to thumb
him up because he just comes in with
everyone whatever he does what he wants
and then we have the mayor with that
long-legged thing I forgot
the long-legged redhead
oh my God
busty and weighty yeah yeah oh hip to
waist ratio was off coming chicken's mum
as well oh they never saw her ahead yeah
you just saw thickness yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
bro
Carlton was back in the day yeah yeah
Johnny Bravo was a massager yes
Johnny brother was [ __ ] yeah it's
just about moving things oh bro he loved
gal he did he loved gal and he he fed
him with the rejection yeah he fed on it
he just used it as gym motivation
oh that was the best [ __ ] anyway oh
right just finished guys
um I've got a anime oh gang of course
you got that cool so this one's short
and sweet okay Bollywood twist in this
one okay there's a Bollywood Twisted I'm
invested already right so a man said
basically I've been casually dating this
girl for near three months now we've
been seeing each other a few times a
week Etc uh and things were going good
last week she actually got together
um oh sorry last week we actually got
together and everything was sweet until
her ex found out and said he'd take her
daughter to live with him if she carried
us on
so obviously she put a stop to the
relationship but we carried on talking
on a daily basis
say that last bit again so I knew that's
why I stopped because I'm not done
they were seeing each other
talking for three months seeing each
other talking every day
last
um last week they made it official
boyfriend and girlfriend and then her
ex-man her baby dad
said to her lock off your boyfriend or
I'm taking full custody okay okay I'm
with you lock your boyfriend off or I'm
taking full custody so she said listen
yeah he's putting me in a Chokehold here
okay leaving me not many options for now
let's put pause on it okay let's just
put a pause on things until I can get
this sorted out oh she's telling the new
brother did she tell the new brother
pause well I swear Baby Daddy sorting
this out okay but they've been talking
every day still okay he loves her oh God
yeah
there was mad feelings coming from both
ends or so I thought okay on Thursday
I'm awake if I'm on Thursday she put a
stop to things completely and then went
out on her with her girls on Friday and
ended up sleeping with someone
how did you find this out
she told me everything Saturday morning
oh my God yeah bro she told me
everything on Saturday morning yeah and
I told her just delete me and leave me
alone bro that that's Thursday and
Friday
no correspondence he it's one of those
he finished by the way no oh sorry sorry
I just want to know am I the [ __ ] for
still wanting her even though she got
with someone else the other day I'm so
confused I've literally never felt like
this about anyone in such a short amount
of time I mean no you're not an [ __ ]
for wanting her I mean you're
just because okay you spoke for every
day for three months she put pause on it
because baby daddy was trying to he was
making up threats making up search
trying to have the upper hand and say
I'm gonna take my child or our child and
take full custody if you keep dealing
with this my brain put that on pause
whatever so they're still talking
they're still talking up until Wednesday
Thursday she stops talking Friday she's
out Saturday she tells him oh I banged
someone last night so he's asking is he
the [ __ ] for still liking her
but still wanting to continue things
um
I think it's more of a question of
[ __ ] or mug also it's not yeah
it's not the terminology I know I can
stand you're trying to stay in the lands
of the segment and I appreciate that
yeah but also it's not what we should be
asking ourselves here the question is
are you a mug yeah
and the answer is yes in my opinion
you're gonna have to be butter because
but it's also man's been talking for
three months straight every day three
months straight every day and we made it
official you're my girlfriend oh you're
the love of my life yeah you're my
girlfriend for the love of my life and
your ex-man is is trifling with us and
the only reason we can't be together is
because he's making threats and she says
just wait for me
we have to stop this because my daughter
comes first and he says say that's what
I love about you that's what I love it
you're a fantastic you are fantastic
that's what I love about the maternal
Edge is what I'm always with you I I
will win I'll wait for you she says say
less until Thursday rolls around and a
girly say out out Friday she's like
pre-ice yes yes yes I need a [ __ ] day
I need a drink
she's like I'm sorry this is getting too
much let's just pause it let I know
we're not together anymore like that but
I just don't think I can do this anymore
he's thinking what the [ __ ] is going on
what's this conference zero to 100 100
zero zero to 100 100 zero she says just
stop talking to man
then she goes out out
gets piped she gets she gets whined and
then she gets done she gets daggered
that yard Bells him Saturday morning
says Fam I'm so sorry she he sees her
Bellingham and he's got gas on Saturday
morning oh we're doing brunch
yeah we're doing our family today we're
doing everything today yeah yeah little
girls with Dad and you want me around
now that's what you're telling me about
it it's Saturday morning little girls
with daddy and you want to see your
daddy the weekend's hours yeah tell me
what you want to do fam I missed you
that's the first thing you see that he
thinks when he sees them I've missed you
babe I've missed you missed you and
she's like babe
listen the tone is different when she
says babe it's hot drops yeah what's
happened what's happened what's
happening what's happening you're right
what's happening what's happening I'm
not gonna lie to you we went out last
night [ __ ] got heated I met a prayer
you say metal but I'm looking at my
phone
I'm locking off the conversation here I
met a prayer you met what I went back to
his
and you obviously know the rest I'm
sorry
I'm sorry why are you doing this to me
that's the first question I'll ask her
why are you doing this tonight I was
just at home waiting for you I've been
waiting for you for 48 hours
and you're calling me to tell me you
went out had a great time and banged
another why are you doing this why not
me why didn't you bang me bro
he's literally waiting for you writing
sonnets and ballads for the weekend
Sonics
and you're calling me to I saw your name
pop up on my phone and I've never been
so happy and now you're telling me it's
done because you bang someone else
bro the worst part is she's not even
telling him it's dumb because she found
someone else she told him it was done
then she banged someone else and now
she's bailing him to begging back oh he
dumped me you then [ __ ] someone else
and now you want me back
um
yeah you will be the mug if you go back
you don't don't go back don't go back
three months is a lot every day I
understand bro but she's she's not the
one she's taking the piss yeah she's
actively intentionally taking the piss
out of you and you need to lock it off
she wants the thing is it was Saturday
morning her kids with the pops she
needed that pancake she wanted that car
door she wanted cyan she realized she
was alone in the house with nothing but
nut and regret inside her facts not
facts filled with nut and regret facts
and she wanted a hangover yeah she
wanted someone that's going to take care
of her yeah and who's been doing that oh
he has let me bet him I'm gonna bail
Scott his name's not Scott but I'm gonna
build obviously I know that
missed you babe not even a hello Farm
Thursday to now felt like a lifetime
where have you been where are you where
are you where are you I'll pick you up
what what are we doing we're doing it
all today yeah why are we doing this to
each other I'm coming to pick you up
today's our day
babe babe I'm filled with not and regret
and my head is pounding just listen shut
up and listen shut up and [ __ ] listen
I miss you too but I need to get this
off my chest first
I held a tool last night and I hated it
I want you back
I know I dumped you out of nowhere
and I knew I and then I banged someone
guilt free
come back
oh man said I want to come back but I'll
be shaking I'm not gonna lie I'll be
shaking I'll throw up I'll be [ __ ]
shaking I'll be firming back the thug
tail I'll be firming it I promise you
I'll throw up
the love of my life yeah the love of my
life just told me that she met at Brett
on a night out because you can't be the
love of my life because you're out here
the [ __ ] guys all nights out this is
the internal tournament I'm going
through because I thought you were up
here but you can't be because you just
went out the day after you dumped me and
banged someone on a night out you're not
the one you're not me you're not the one
for me you're trying to convince me
otherwise and you're trying to crawl
crawl backed up to my space
even though you know I want you and I'm
grieving from Thursday still you're
kicking sound in my eyes
I'm still hurt from Thursday and this is
the next thing you have to say to me
I'm just there looking at my phone like
yeah it's starting to understand bro
please don't go yeah you can't literally
a car it's literally done you can't I'm
sorry it's done this episode is done and
this is done because this is foolishness
you can't and it's just gonna cause you
pain yeah facts facts it's gonna cause
you bear pain bro because you're going
to be wondering if you're still chatting
to man what's gonna happen on the next
night out the day every time she's got a
night out planned am I gonna be
expecting a text saying we're done [ __ ]
off like what is this block a number
block a number and delete off of Socials
because you need to start fresh you need
to block it you need to turn a new Leaf
there was a little tidbit in there that
has clocked which is the most beta thing
that you can do and I don't ever want to
see a grown man like you do this again
what did he say he'd hold her after she
um said what she said he told her block
me on everything
he didn't block her he told her block me
on everything which means
he's a yeah I'm sorry but bro that's the
youngest thing I've ever heard is
because no offense don't take this wrong
way I know you're hurting but you're so
heartbeat that you haven't got the balls
to block her so you're begging her to do
it because you physically can't do it
because you need to see her everywhere
you need to see her face somewhere every
day profile picture so you can't bring
yourself to block her so you've asked
her Please block me just please block me
because I can't oh that's hard deal with
this it's heartbreaking but it's moist
and we can't stand for it it's hard
right you're a grown man blocker you
have to block her just block her
heartbreak James it is
we've been there and we've got past it
you need to get past it to block her for
the love of God be a man and block her I
said please for the love of God just
block me just block me because I can't
do this I can't he was crying when he
said it
and his screen was full of tears because
he had to wiping screen so many times
for eight percent it was full it is oh
bro the heat from the tears were just
pressing keys
ah bro man's auto correcting the whole
thing I don't want to wait anymore it's
done lock it yeah blocker yeah move on
you deserve better bro thanks thank you
guys as always if you want to catch an
episode on Thursday head on over to
patreon.com shits and gigs and we're
happy to have you
become part of the cult babies love love
love
[Music]